الفنانه رزان جمال اهلا بيكي بصراحه
العربيه بس كثير همم دور ساره في مسلسل
الثمن اا يمكن ناس كثير تفاعلت معه وحاسه
يعني ان هم حاسين بصاره وازمتها اا كتير
اا ايه الخصوصيه في الدور ده وازاي
استعادتي له يعني يا اللي بيميزها انه هي
بموقف كثير صعب
والناس عم بيقدر يتعاطف و بالوضع هي يعني
الموقف يا اللي هي فيه همم
يعني همم اشتغلت كثير لدور السعر ما كان
عندي غير الاول 10 حلقات مكتوبين بالاول
قعدت لها شهرين
كثير اشتغلت على لا تعلم شو شو شو شو مين
ساره من اول اتعرف عليها همم
اه انا كنت عم حارب كمان عايش امي وللاسف
خسرت الله يرحمها همم يا اللي عاشته ساره
انا كمان عاشته بالحقيقه بالحقيقه
ساره فيها مزيج من القوه الداخليه وفي نفس
الوقت الحنان والطيبه والهل ده او
الرومانسيه نقدر
نختلف عن همم
انسان كثير
منيحه هي شخص كثير
شوف اذا شخصيه بتناسبني
على القصه بتطلع على المخرج عن الممثلين
على كل الكاس على كل على كل شيء
بس اهم شيء القصه بهذا العمل قبل ما اقرا
اي شيء عرضوا علي العبده وساره وماكن في
بعض ناس
فبعثوا لي اول كم حلقه بس من المسلسل
القديم يعني عم نستوحي منه ما هلا بتشوفوا
مع الوقت انه تغيرت وحطينا اللمسه تبعيتنا
وهي النسخه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اشتغل مع مروان حامد
والكامبو بعد ما حضرت له 1000 انت كمان
كثير عجبنا الكومبو تبع احمد مراد ومروان
حامد لما اجينا الفرصه انه اشتغل كمان مع
كاست تعذيب احمد عز كريم عبد العزيز هند
صبري اللي اشتغلنا مع بعض قبل طالعه انا
اكيد همم كثير كثير حبيت الفيلم انا يعني
غدر الناس ان انا املي بالفيلم رائع هل هل
حسيت ده يمكن قربت او كان خطوه في ان هو
تقربي للجمهور المصري اول تجربه مصر كانت
مع
هندسه
كثير حلو لانه بلاش
كثير فعلا
بالوطن العربي
فكل حياته جمهور المصري عنده عنده محل خاص
بقلبي لانه اول شعب دعمني رزان انت مثلتي
بالمصري وباللبناني وبال بالانجليزي
وشاركتي في اعمال
اجنبيه او اعمال عالميه انت بتحسي انك
اقرب لايه متجهه لايه اكتر بصراحه بلش في
الاول بلشت في العالميه وبعدين
برنت اكثر صوب الوطن العربي لما اجاني فرص
حلوه بالوطن العربي ما تفكر وين بدي اكون
انا الحمد لله
لك يا فنانه عربي
[موسيقى]
همم
كانت صعبه
لا اتنفس شويه قبل ما ارجع ضبط بالشيء
دراما بس انا بقول هيك
شكرا رزان وبالتوفيق ان شاء الله كثير